vrai les gens
[Applaudissements]
rejoindre les deux gérard gérard jugnot
et gérard louvin qui sont en karting
regardez alors attention on voit bien
donc gérard jugnot est en rouge jura
louvard et andré gérard louvin sans
déconner on dérégule jean loup on voit
même pas de carte sur un cardigan
giacchino honneur le gars que j'adore et
sans lunettes
autant vous dire est que c'est peut-être
la dernière séquence gt legends gérard
louvin c'était le groupe a dit gérard
louvin c'était marjolaine et les
millionnaires
c'était greg le millionnaire c'était
l'île de la tentation et bien
aujourd'hui gérard louvin c'est le crash
oliva et trois tours donc gérard jugnot
contre gérard louvin gérard tout va bien
tout va bien janin qui va nous le club
pour l'instant attention 3 2
c'est celle où vingt cas pris la tête
lula qui a pris la tête pour l'instant
il faut il doit faire trois tours
attention on va il est bien calé
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hu
oui
m
rageant
oh
[Musique]
regardez comment gérard chevrot chez le
kart gérer vos impressions après la
course c'est tout mon petit c'est tout
je veux gagner parce que je suis
touche pas à mon poste je suis un
gagneur comme monsieur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'étais trop vite de plus gérard et moi
et pour moi c'est un bonheur en tout cas
pour moi aussi je ne sais pas pour vous
mais la compagnie à gaza c'est vrai elle
est folle de vous je crois votre
compagne iphone os et vous pourriez lui
faire la petite danse mais je sais pour
votre c'est pourquoi la cc pour la la la
compagne de gérard jugnot diana jaffe
laquelle alassane est où la danse de
l'école de danse orientale d'accord et
la danse des preuves adoré ça ça c'est
pas la décision appartient
et le conte de fées là il est aussi bill
à la grève dépend mode dj là on
l'appelle oui on a une commande
boulevards des maréchaux pour une
personne qui va les aéroports tu peux y
aller ou pas il est dans notre taxi il
n'est pas si vide j'ai c'est le seul
didier qui me laisse danser sur les
excès de la caméra jugnot cayla on se
donne un mal fou ça y est ils sont nuls
en arrêt la foule à brax faux belle
mentalité
bon j'espère que ça lui a plu même sans
musique merci gérard en tout cas d'être
là
[Musique]